okay so the first trailer for Craven the
hunter has just hit the web and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the Easter eggs hidden
details and things you missed in it your
friendly neighborhood spoiler man is
back and in this video I want to talk
about what we know about the film along
with what's been shown in the teaser
there's also lots of comic book things
to discuss too and in case you're
unaware of Craven then this is the video
you've been craving sorry sorry are also
making a lot of noise with him at the
moment and we also know that his Studio
appear in the upcoming Spider-Man 2 game
that seems to be based Loosely on the
Ultimate Comics run which had him
traveling to New York to tackle the
Webhead whereas this is gonna be more of
an origin story in the comics he was a
big enemy to Peter and was also known as
Peter's worst enemy I bet things have
been changed up for this with a film
adaptation and he's being described as
being an animal lover he also has his
own meta human abilities now with a line
attack leading to him being able to
doctor do little things and communicate
with animals this is a an extra layer
that hasn't been in the comics before
with him employing wolves to help him
hunt people down now we get to his
abilities because he refused to shoot a
lion under the direction from his father
and this then left out and started to
attack him science it's all based on
signs and he says that he stared death
in the face and we can even see a tarot
card of this being pulled out I think
that this is probably from Calypso who
is a character we'll talk about later on
in the video eventually he's dealing
death to those that try and harm animals
which is gonna put him at odds with his
own dad he of course wants Craven to
shoot and kill a line at one point and
makes it clear that this shows strength
we'll see how that works out but it's
also been stated that he's more of a
conservationist here that's quite clear
from the way this trailer plays out with
it being bloody and brutal when it comes
to humans but not really too bad in
terms of hunting Wildlife I know that
this has become a bit of a sore point
for fans as Craven was basically a super
villain Safari Hunter but I I still
think they can make stuff work with the
R rating even if we're getting craving
the vegan when you think about it
Craven's now for hunting Spider-Man who
is of course a human so they can
probably get around there but yeah but
we're gonna see anyway Craven first
debuted in 1964's Amazing Spider-Man 15
and since then we've learned the ins and
outs of his backstory born to a Russian
Aristocrats sergey's dad Nikolai fled to
the US during the Russian Revolution in
order to escape the persecution of the
elite they obviously can't really use
that due to the event taking place in
1917 so I think they'll probably go with
something more modern like the fall of
the Soviet Union or something anyway
Craven's father in the film will be
played by Russell Crowe who we hear
narrating the trailer at several points
this teaser was actually shown at
cinemacon a couple of months back and
apparently had a couple of different
lines to what we get here I'm not sure
as I can't fully compare it but I did
get told that the general theme was
overall the same so we aren't really
missing that much I think they are gonna
alter things slightly from the comics
though as we don't learn that much about
him but we do know that Nikolai is
pretty different to what Crow's supposed
to be doing here Nikolai supposedly just
bought a place in New York after fleeing
Saint Petersburg and his son kind of
went off and did things on his own now
he's clearly the bad guy here with
Craven saying that his father puts evil
into the world while he takes it out
also important to bear in mind that
there's lots of different cuts of this
teaser going about so if I mentioned
something that's not the one you saw
then my bad there's just so many
versions of it the one released at
cinemacon also had Craven traveling to
more locations and at one point we see
him coming across his classic costume
this was shown at a different angle to
how it appears here with us getting more
of the shot inside the box which changes
things up though they pitched it as
being his I think it probably belonged
to his dad and that he's gonna inherit
it come the end of the film I can kind
of see him taking on a sort of racial or
Razz Al ghoul as it is in Batman Begins
and though there's a couple of different
villains in the teaser I think we might
get to miss RX over who the true one
actually is and I bet right and I'd put
money on this knowing Sony but I bet the
best thing is uh from the post credit
scene because they're idiots
they just can't help themselves now in
case you don't know Craven's half
brother is actually the chameleon and we
know that he's going to be played in the
film by Fred hetchinger the chameleon is
a Master of Disguise he's the perfect
mimic and he's up there as being one of
my favorite villains in the spider-verse
one of the first comic book runs I ever
read was when he impersonated Jay Jonah
Jameson which I still think I might have
lying around need to Ebay that no I
bought that at a comic book store when I
was about 14 and reading through it page
to page it was such a good run that
gives me Faith they can do a lot with
the character I'm really surprised that
they've never properly lent into using
him in live action before and I was sure
that they were going to with him being a
shield agent far from home but alas that
didn't happen however I think having
this big Family Feud would be a really
cool way to take things and that sort of
takes me into theater
Peter and the main person they're
showing off in the teaser is of course
the Rhino played by Alessandro navola
you might recognize the actor from
Face-Off and Jurassic Park 3. the Rhino
is of course a classic Spider-Man
villain and he's probably one of the big
Mainstays when it comes to bosses that
the wall crawler has to tackle I've
beaten him on a number of games read a
number of stories with him and he also
of course popped up an Amazing
Spider-Man too this idea of there being
variant rhinos was also present and
across the spider-verse as we had a
multitude of rhinos appearing in the
background of that cell scene typically
in the comics Rhino tends to be a guy in
a suit whereas here they're using
chemicals to transform him into a human
Rhino hybrid now if we look at the
comics it actually makes a lot of sense
to have him being one of the big
villains firstly he's a rhino so he
ticks the hunting box but beyond that
the characters also rushing in the
source material Alexis systemic Circle
he was
experimented on with Kim chemical and
radiation treatments and these increased
his size and strength from this point
onwards he started to rock the Rhino
armor which began to bond with his skin
he wasn't actually able to remove it for
years in the comics whereas here he's
done it through more of a transformation
it's possible that the serum has other
applications too and we might see it
turning other characters into types of
animals say right getting on Theory time
again here say chameleon takes it and
turns into a chameleon he could look you
get the idea of that now the trailer
that I saw begins in what looks like the
Charlie old foggy Streets of London also
if you can hear my kids screaming in the
background apologies for that I'm I'm
like Russell Crowe in this movie I'm
trying to get them involved in the
spoiler game but they just wouldn't ruin
it all now we've got them big red buses
and British license plate and it brings
it brings it to your wi Craven jumps on
top of a car at one point and takes the
drivers out showing that he's more
equipped than most to take down his
father sounds like my kids are trying to
take down this channel too and the
cinema con trailer did things slightly
differently as that had a number of
mercenaries hunting for him out in
Africa which is when he got the drop on
them that then went to him wielding his
classic machete and this was a weapon
that he carried in the comics instantly
lets you know the movies hit her ear and
it's R rating and it's probably the
smartest thing that they could have done
and one thing that I never really got
with the Sony Spider-Man spin-off
stories is that they never really lent
into how violent these things could be
it seems scared to take the plunge and
instead of getting bad guys all the
characters just seemed to be anti-heroes
though that's the case here with Craven
yeah he fits that a lot better than a
living vampire and a symbiote so it at
least makes more sense here however we
had stuff like the Carnage origin story
that should have easily been a hard oh
and instead they turned it right down so
I'm glad they're finally leaning in with
it and taking it in the right direction
for this character now when I talked
about him being an anti-hero I actually
think that Craven's one of the most
complicated characters in comics if
you've ever read Craven's last hunt then
you'll know it deals with the complexity
of mental health issues and it ends with
character taking his own life desperate
to be remembered as the greatest he
actually manages to beat Spider-Man and
he buries him alive at the midpoint of
the story it's a really big thing that
they could do in future films and I
think Aaron Taylor-Johnson could
actually carry this off a craven is
clearly leaning into more being like his
mother who we learned died when he and
his brother were in their teens their
father said she was weak and thus he has
had an influence over them he only cares
about honor and power and and sees
killing animals as a form of trophies
his brother at one point says that he's
exactly like their dad just another man
hunting for a trophy this idea of being
after a trophy is something that's
followed Craven through every iteration
the Ultimate Universe had him being a
sort of Steve Irwin TV star but rather
than protecting animals he hunted them
for the camera this is what took him to
New York which is where he wanted to
arrest Spider-Man on screen which would
cement him as the greatest however he
was unable to do this and he ended up
being embarrassed multiple times
throughout and the reason I'm bringing
this up is to show how important Legacy
is to the character and we get the idea
that he hasn't really made his name yet
he's out to hunt show is the best and
become someone who's known as the
world's greatest Predator probably could
have worded that better sit down Chris
antonietta that didn't mean it like that
on top of this we also know that Arya
and the boss will be playing Calypso a
voodoo priestess who did the thing
Viola Davis the boss broke the internet
with her bafta wrap
[Music]
turn it off turn it off but Calypso is
actually a pretty big character in the
comics a big love interest of Craven she
somewhat caused the death of the
character by constantly telling him
about Spider-Man which pushed him
towards a choice he made little is known
about her role in the movie but we do
know that she'll be taking on the
position of his lower so they are
following things closely and we also
have spiders dropping down on him out in
the woods this is obviously some
Spider-Man tying or something with it
showing how he's attached that world
even though we'll never meet him I
wonder how they're gonna handle it and
it kind of reminds me of when Carnage
killed that one in venom 2 where it
probably won't go anywhere now the
trailer I saw ends with the tagline
nothing survives the hunt which has a
double meaning to it as Craven's gonna
be leaving nothing alive in his wake but
it's also playing on the fact that he's
gonna lose himself in doing that I know
they're trying to keep him as an
anti-hero but I'd love for them to
tackle some stuff like how this Quest
will eventually cost him his soul sure
he'll gain a name but he'll lose the the
person behind it and I'm really hoping
that they dive into that idea for the
final film now that wraps things up and
you know after seeing this I was very
hopeful but this didn't knock it out the
park for me I have enjoyed their
trailers in the past but every time I've
went to one of these movies It's Made Me
Realize they're not that good and now I
have a guilty pleasure in venom you know
there's there's lots of things wrong
with their Universe at the moment I
personally don't think it's gonna be a
groundbreaking piece of Cinema but the
Venoms like I said have always been
guilty pleasures and at least with
Mobius we did get the memes now I am
hoping that with them leaning into the R
rating that it's the right thing to do
and that this is finally gonna go in the
direction that Sony should be going I
think this movie you know with Sony so
it probably will do well but you can
kind of predict all the plot beats just
off this trailer alone guessing that
it's a big origin story Craven belt is
rapper his brother betrays him and he
has to run off out into the world
basically the plot of Mobius as well but
yeah we're not Reinventing the wheel
here so yeah I can kind of guess how I
feel from that um you know I'm tempering
my expectations and I want to be excited
but this wasn't a home run for me
however I will of course keep you up to
date with the movie I'm hoping that we
get a lot of things that look better and
the more we learn about it obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on it am I
being a Negative Nancy you know tell me
below if you liked it as I'd love to
hear from you guys to see if there's
something I missed and should appreciate
more about it if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
one of our videos linked on screen now
and hopefully I see you over there right
after this huge thank you for sticking
through this with me I hope you enjoyed
the breakdown and yeah also hopefully
see you over at the channel very soon by
the way enjoy the rest of your week mate
you take care peace